und leute was man auch sagen musst du
kannst jetzt mal darauf achten ob gegen
das auffällt was sie besser gemacht
hättest als nur noch mehr tätig ist
sondern den anfang machen du kannst ja
schon
hey leute was geht ab herzlich
willkommen zu unserem zweiten part von
dem mcdonalds interview nicht mal eben
den ersten paar schon gedreht ist eine
täterbeschreibung verlinkt ich habe die
carbo dabei karat von 2018 bis 2019
vaillant gearbeitet und meinte ich würde
ihnen vorbeikommen die ein paar fragen
beantworten die du immer so hasst und
deswegen sitzen wir jetzt gerade hier im
auto und ich hab mir halt jetzt
zusätzlich überlegt weil das ein
bisschen langweilig ist einfach dann
oben in der wohnung zu sitzen und
beantwortete die fragen waren wir doch
mal eben einfach zu mcdonalds und ich
stell dir währenddessen halt die frage
wir haben noch zehn fragen die leute
haben extrem viele fragen gestellt
deswegen machen wir es dann immer ganz
spontan im auto aber ich kann euch auf
den ersten part ans herz legen wir nicht
gesehen habt glaube das ist so ein
bisschen ruhiger und entspannter und da
haben wir auf jeden fall auch schon mal
so den ganzen wichtigsten fragen und die
die am häufigsten gestellt wurden ja
beantworten ist die frage die ich auch
noch auf bekommen haben soll von 2018
bis 2019 gearbeitet und du hast ja eben
schon mal erklärt wie du darauf gekommen
ist oder daß du halt einfach sein abi
gemacht was und noch auf jemand 50 euro
basis gearbeitet und was machst du jetzt
also du hast ja dann gekündigt und was
arbeitest
also das ist immer noch so restaurant
und was gefällt dir besser ja dass dort
bei mcdonalds oder das jetzt das kann
ich gar nicht sagen weil ich finde in
unterschiedlicher also man nimmt
unterschiedliche erfahrungen mit und ich
finde dass man auswirkt handel schon
eine menge lernen kann vor allem auch
mit dem unser umgang mit den menschen
selbst viel fall man muss ja auch auf
alles gefasst sein also wie ich halt
erzählt habe das ist auch echt
unhöfliche raum gibt die einen sofort an
brillen zb wenn irgendetwas nicht passt
nicht reicht dann eben mal kurz zuvor
gesprochen über stunden werden die
bezahlt wenn ihr da arbeitest ja
natürlich erhöhen also überstanden
aber dass ich von herzig mehr das
gleiche
wahrscheinlich weiß nicht woher also wir
sind jetzt hier schon dass es so der
stadt begonnen
er hat auch mal 24 7 auf und an diesen
mcdonnell bei sich sehr zu schätzen er
ist immer für mich wenn ich halt machen
wenn ich halt mal ein video dann drehe
wo es neue sachen gibt die haben immer
alles und das ist ja so auf dem dorf zum
beispiel sowie haben das dann nicht
schnell wenn man halt irgendwas neues
eingeführt was willst du deswegen wasser
trinken
eigentlich nicht und leute was man auch
sagen musst du kannst du jetzt mal
darauf achten ob die etwas auffällt was
du besser gemacht hättest als du noch
hier tätig war
hallo ich hätte gerne ein mix an der
schoko oder dann ein mc sunday saurer
apfel ja und diese
[Musik]
ach so ja auch hier darum die das wird
schon danke werde zb auf mich so ein
bisschen sohn ich will nicht sagen
unmöglich aber es hat er keinen bock
oder dankeschön also den 1 cent ist
hielt er den etwas trinken das ist das
wird entweder in die normale und was
hast du jetzt für den gebracht das die
meisten verloren
also manchmal habe ich hier ich habe
ihren freund eigentlich den denn der
bedienung ich sonst immer auch bei
meinen bestellungen halt da haben wir
eben auch schon mal kurz zuvor
gesprochen weil ich halt so was großes
auf nehme oder keine ahnung
er kennt mich glaube ich schon und da
kann man eigentlich auch direkt finden
zur nächsten frage und zwar was war die
teuersten bestellung die du je
aufgenommen hast ihn teuer sind die echt
aufgenommen wonach die bei euch
aufgegeben wurde also ich glaube in dem
trias mit 83 ich bin ich sicher mehr
nicht ich weiß es nicht
da kann ich halt direkt zu sagen
ich will jetzt nicht angeben oder so
aber auf meinem ersten bestellung erhält
das doppelte davon von den 380 euro das
ja gar nix
dann haben wir hier noch mich in
erinnerung aber nicht kümmern damit für
die einstellung eines meintest du auf
das man eigentlich gar keinen bock auf
sowas sonst hätte ich jetzt gar nicht
gedacht weil das hier auch um gut so
aber will man zwar keine plätzchen
gesucht wenn wir nochmal im urin können
das habe ich hier sogar mein anfang
april in köln
hast du dir gerne was war dein
lieblingsessen was sodann halt wenn nur
mal dort gegessen hast genommen hast
also meistens esse ich auch können
was würdest du sagen wie ist die
qualität von dem fleisch das okay das
kriegt man auch als mitarbeiter
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr weil ich hab
gelesen viele haben geschrieben woran
liegt es dass mcdonald's sehr oft mit
der qualität von rindfleisch wirkt aber
vom hähnchen vielleicht eher nicht so
weißt du ja es gab ja auch diese
amerikanischen dokus die haben ja das
mit dem lena fleisch dass die so dass
dieser seine klasse und so gefertigt
werden das seminar geschreddert werden
dann wird auch diese und da kann ich
auch an dieser stelle nochmal sagen
schaut euch auf jeden fall in erst
partnern und ich habe ja auch eben schon
mal gesagt vielleicht war ich da wir
noch mal mit jemandem der mal bei
lieferando gearbeitet hat als fahrer bei
burger king oder bei bader meldet euch
bei mir bei instagram alex wie konnte
mir sehr gerne schreiben mal gucken was
die leute noch geschrieben haben
verdient man unterschiedlicher man in
der küche arbeitet war wenn man an der
kasse arbeitet soweit ich weiss nicht
komplett die natürlich arbeiten arbeiten
meistens halt schon mehr als 55 und die
arbeiten dann auch in der woche deutlich
öfter sagen weil die schüler die sich
dann einfach nur nebenbei was verdienen
wollen können
jetzt weißt wie alles zubereitet da
haben wir 21 zubereitet wird würdest du
oder ist dort selber noch ich war ja
pokal zum ersten werkes nach also zum
essen
mit dem verkauf der gläser und sagen
denn diesen den neuen sachen da habe ich
halt auch mal sachen gegessen also wird
trotzdem auch erst mal so was nicht
schlecht ist gesehen ich habe jetzt
nichts erschreckendes gesehen hast du
das mal probiert und auch so über
betrunkene leute haben wir im ersten
quartal gesprochen dass du heute nacht
auch dann so an gebacken der nachfolger
fliegen
[Musik]
wir hatten mal einen kunden der beim
ersten fenster und das war ich schätze
mal der war auch so ich sag jetzt mal
älter als 17 18 denke ich mal aber der
kam da im auto mit seiner oma angefahren
und seine jungs schwimmen
seine oma ist halt gefahren und dann hat
er sowas gestellt ist aber torkeln zum
ersten dienstag aus dem auto
ausgestiegen dann ist das zum zweiten
fenster gelaufen und hat dann so sachen
gebracht wie hat eigentlich weh getan
leiste gehören mir gefallen ist und ob
ich meine arbeit klingen wohin ich mit
ihm nach vegas vorausgesagt das piep
piep ja überall andauernd wenn da
irgendwas fertig ist also ganz auf die
eier ermittelt oder blendet man das
gehört einfach dazu
anfangs ist echt nervig und irgendwann
hat man auch die schnauze voll wenn
irgendwer dann lass dich ausmacht denn
wir haben auch gefragt was ich weiß dass
jetzt gar nicht was ich damit meinen was
haben die zahlen auf dem bildschirm zu
bedeuten weißt du was du also irgendwie
wahrscheinlich haben die produkte
verschiedener nummer
auf dem bildschirm mit einer nummer weiß
ich jetzt also keine ahnung also ich
weiß nicht was damit gemeint ist der
nacht zu sonntag gearbeitet also erst
habe ich das lieber was das habe ich
unter der woche gearbeitet das fand ich
gar nicht mal so schlecht
aber auf dauer fand ich das irgendwie
ich weiß nicht ob da hat mich die
nachtschicht lieber gefallen auch wenn
sie echt anstrengend und hat war
aufregender genau da waren auch leicht
weil da waren halt die witzigsten sachen
gesagt die geschichte eben auch dass man
richtig bekannt wird dadurch wenn man
bei mcdonald's arbeitet bei immer auch
leute in seiner altersgruppe kommen und
klar so ich kann auch bei mir jetzt
leute die mit uns arbeiten und kann vom
gesicht her weiß wenn ich hier in der
stadt sehr weil ich dachte doch bei
mcdonald also dass man halt bekannt wird
so oder auch viele freunde von mir
kommen und dich dann halt dort mit der
scheidung also das stimmt schon es ist
ein tag wo ich mit einem freund von mir
bei mcdonald's war erst vor kurzem ich
hingegangen und alle meine linke hand
gesagt haben
und so war es dann auch mal so dass ich
kenne das ja selber von mir so ich werde
auf der straße sowie kann sogar guck mal
der macht und youtube-videos und bei dir
klar aber ist er trotzdem lustig so
keine ahnung also ich hab mir jetzt
nicht so wieder fragen gestellt auch im
ersten part schon wer bestimmt 20 25
fragen waren wurde ich würde sagen jetzt
rechnung eingehen oder hast du noch
irgendwas wo du sagen willst dass das
würde ich noch gerne erzählen
[Musik]
ja so komische leute also wenn ihr
nachts unterwegs sind und zunächst folgt
dann am besten auch nichts was soll ich
andere leute irgendwann oder wie ja auch
also unter anderem ja genau das ist
meine bei max ist und nachts alle von
einer disco kommen so dass man sich
nicht erst als frau von männern anlage
ähnlich aber das ist gut für major dann
danke dass wir dabei was er gesagt hat
ich bin erst dann wenn das noch nicht
gesehen hat der mainzer im august auch
in der bio bestellung verlinkt und wir
sehen unseren morgen 19 uhr weil ich
mache jeden tag ein video und wir müssen
jetzt entsprechend also bist du eben
größer so meine schwester ich grüße
meine kleine schwester christina und
falls dass sie es kann sich gedrückt
du hast ja auch drauf gewartet